hi and welcome to this new tutorial
series to create a neural network in
JavaScript which we will hopefully use
to automate the game asteroids now we
made this game asteroids in another
tutorial series so feel free to check
that out you can download the code from
the links below and there should be a
sounds folder and an HTML file so let's
open the game up so there's a triangular
ship that can be moved around the string
and it can shoot the asteroids I'll just
meet that so the goal of this tutorial
series is a very simple one and
intentionally so because new neural
networks can be quite challenging the
goal is to rotate towards the closest
asteroid and shoot rotate to the next
closest asteroid and shoot it's not
going to be an algorithm we're going to
train a neural network to do this so
what is a neural network well here it is
basically they're made up of a number of
layers so in the input layer a hidden
layer and an output layer you can't have
multiple hidden layers but we'll focus
on just having a single hidden layer to
keep things simple now the input layer
it will take our game information so we
could pass things such as the angle to
the nearest asteroid or the current
angle of the ship the hidden layer is
more like a processing layer I guess and
the output well we'll probably have a
single output whether to turn left or
turn right so it'll be a single boolean
so 0 will mean left 1 will mean right
will keep things nice and simple because
these things can be quite complicated in
between each of these layers there's a
whole bunch of black arrows now each of
these black arrows represent a weight a
weight between minus 1 and 1 I believe
so for each neuron in the previous layer
it sends out information to each of the
neurons in the next layer so ultimately
we'll be sending in some training data
for example the asteroid position and
the ship's current angle or something
similar and we'll feed that through with
the neck
expected output so either to turn left
or turn right now if it gets it wrong
we'll send that information back to the
import I guess and use that to correct
these weights so ultimately we'll be
sending in thousands of points of
information correcting these weights
until finally we have a unique set of
weights that can take any of our gain
information and give us an accurate and
reliable output so here's the position
of an asteroid what do I do
turn left here's another position of a
different asteroid what do I do
turn right let's just close that down
we'll have to create a new javascript
file just a plain text document called
say neural network neural network and
give that the j/s extension yes and open
both of those in your favorite editor
I'm using Visual Studio code here so the
first thing we should do is set up a
flag to let us know that automation is
on so currently we have a whole bunch of
flags in here how about we pull them out
and we'll put them in a different
section just to make it a little bit
tighter yeah how about developer Flags
paste them in there sorry just doing
some housekeeping so let's create a new
constant called automation automation on
we'll set that to true initially so when
the automation is on we'll want to set
up our neural network so just after we
set up the game parameters here so after
new game here set up the neural network
so if automation is on let's leave
ourselves to do here because we can't do
it at the moment to do neural network
good now also when the automation is on
we don't want the player to be able to
to control the ship do we so down in our
key press functions so key it key down
yep here we go keydown and keyup so if
the ship is dead or automation is on
return don't do anything so they can
press the keys as much as they like
nothing will happen
similarly in the key up method if ship
is dead or automation is on return we'll
let the computer control the ship
speaking of computers controlling ships
let's head down to the update function
that's where all the objects drawn and
moved and so on so just the start of the
update function just that me here
somewhere how about we say use the
neural network to control to rotate the
ship and shoot and shoot so again we'll
just leave ourselves so if Adam ation is
on believe ourselves to do here so do
control ship okay good let's just make
sure that we haven't broken anything so
head up the top
first of all let's try it with the
automation flag on okay so I'm moving
the arrow keys I'm pushing the spacebar
nothing's happened and just to make sure
that we haven't broken anything let's
set it to false
yeah I can control the ship in that
situation so when it's turned on when
it's true I've lost control of the ship
awesome now head over to our new file
and neural network J s at the top of
that file let's use a flag use strict
now want to use strict does it basically
enforces good coding practice things
like you must declare variables and so
on we're also going to focus on es6
javascript now es6 is like the latest
major revision to JavaScript syntax
things like class and constructors and
so on so we're going to use that we'll
try to use that throughout this tutorial
series
now neural networks use a lot of maths
specifically matrix maths so how about
we create a heading in called matrix
functions a matrix is essentially just
two-dimensional array so it has a number
of rows and a number of columns so I'm
just making this stand out a little bit
matrix functions there we go so how can
we represent a matrix well how about we
represent it as a class so class matrix
give it a constructor the constructor
will take a number of rows and a number
of columns and how about optionally
we'll have data here as well so if we
put an equal sign here it's a default
value so the by default it will be an
empty array so inside the constructor
let's set the variables
now usually private variables private
instance variables are prefixed with an
underscore so we'll follow that
convention do the same sort of thing for
the columns and the data calls and data
and access those variables we should put
some getters so just get rows
and all that does is return this dot
underscore rose and do a similar thing
for each of the other variables calls
data this calls and this data so to use
that when we declare an instance of this
matrix
we'd go matrix dot rows and that would
return this dot rows so inside the
constructor let's initialize initialize
with zeros initialize with the zeros if
no data provided so if data equals null
somebody could pass null couldn't they
or data dot length equals zero so in the
default case that's true if either of
those things occur then we want to
populate this data this data will equal
a new empty array now let the loop
through each of the rows so for let I
equals 0 so that is one of these New
Year six words basically it means that I
is only visible within the for loop that
I equals 0 I is less than this Rose I
plus plus lowercase I plus plus will
want to initialize the road so this data
I will equal an empty array and will
loop through each of the columns so let
J equals 0 J is less than this calls J
plus plus
this data will this data I J so we'll
set each of the elements to equal zero
but if data is passed we'll probably
want to check its integrity for example
somebody could put three rows three
columns but provide data with only two
rows so that's not good is it
so let's put an else here else we'll
check data integrity so if the data is
length doesn't equal the row number
doesn't equal rows or data maybe data 0
dot length so that's the column length
isn't it doesn't equal coals then let's
throw a new era so throw new error now
the error takes a message you can just
put something like incorrect data
dimensions that should be enough so
let's test this let's go back to our
main file we'll have to import that file
so we can do that up in the style script
create script tags so script and we'll
need a type type will equal text
JavaScript and the source will equal dot
size sorry dot slash that means the
current directory neural network
whatever we named our file neural
network jeaious close the script tags so
head down to where we will initialize or
set up our neural network just in here
let's try to set up some matrices so let
m 0 equal new matrix rows say 2 rows 3
columns and let's output that to make
sure that it's working we could probably
use the table command here
because it outputs table
data tabular data so M 0 dot data that's
the data of our matrix let's take a look
at that just need to open the console
here we go we have a two by three matrix
full of zeros that's good let's try to
pass some data so we can do that by
setting up an array here so an array of
arrays I should say so two one just
adding some values here and the next row
four three four three zero say okay
let's give that a go yeah we go to 1
minus 1 4 3 0 2 1 minus 1 4 3 0 now what
if we declared the incorrect dimension
here too so we said if a 3x3 matrix
instead of a 2x3 let's check our error
checking good error incorrect data
dimensions
put that back to awesome
head to our other file to create another
function so let's create a function that
randomizes the weights or creates a
random set of weights remember between
our neurons there's going to be some
weights between minus 1 and 1 so let's
create a function for that so apply
random weights between minus 1 and 1
so we'll call this random weights so
this is inside our class for let's I
equals 0 I is less than this dot rows I
plus plus
for the columns for let J equals zero J
is less than this dot columns J plus
plus this dot data I J will equal
math.random that's a number between 0 &
1 times 2 times 2 minus 1 so a random
number between 0 & 2 minus 1 is minus 1
between minus 1 and positive 1 good
let's test it in our other file so on m0
we can just go m0 dot random weights and
hopefully that should work so currently
that's what it looks like let's run it
ah there we go yep that looks good too
forgot some random weights negative is
positive and everything in between
great head to our other file and let's
create our next method add two matrices
so we'll make this a static method that
just means we don't have to instantiate
the class we can just call it directly
we can go matrix dot add it will require
two matrices m0 and m1 we'll probably
want to check that them to make sure
that they have the same dimension so we
can go we'll create a new method a new
static method matrix to check dimensions
it will require m0 and m1 let's create
that now actually so check matrices have
the same
dimension same dimensions so static
check dimensions m0 and m1 if MZ if m 0
dot rows doesn't equal m1 dot rows or m
0 dot coles doesn't equal m1 dot Cole's
then let's just throw a new error throw
new error the message we could about
matrices are of different dimensions
okay so we checked that now we'll need
to create a you know add method we'll
need to create a new return matrix so
let m equal new matrix the rows will
just be the same as what's passed so M 0
rows M 0 dot columns and we'll need to
loop through each of those so let i
equals 0 i is less than m dot rows i
plus plus and another loop for let's J
equals 0 J is less than M Coles J plus
plus
what will we do here so M data I J will
equal I'll just copy that M 0 M 0 dot
data i J plus M 1 dot data I J so it is
adding the each individual cells
together and assigning it to the new
matrix and we'll have to return that
matrix return M ok let's test that in
our other file first we need a couple of
more matrices to test with so let's
create two more m 1 which will be 2 by 3
and just to change up some of these
numbers here that will do and M 2 will
be a different size to matrix a 2 by 2
so let's just delete that's okay good
let's try it we don't need to use this
random weights anymore let's try to add
M 1 and M 2 it shouldn't work because
they are being invalid so they're of
different dimensions so matrix dot add M
1 M 2 let's try that error matrices are
of different dimensions and that's in
the that's on line 81 yep that's correct
how about we try to add M 0 well m m0
and m1 they should add we'll probably
want to print out the data before we add
them m0 data m1 data and we'll print out
this data
there we go so we'll add that and show
the data of the result matrix okay so
the first matrix 2 1 1 4 3 0 next matrix
2 1 blah blah so adding each of these so
2 plus 0 equals 0 sorry
three plus 0 equals 2 4 plus 2 equals 6
that's right 1 plus 1 equals 2 3 plus
minus 3 0 minus 1 plus minus 1 is minus
2 and 0 plus 0 0 plus 0 equals 0 good
adding works head back to our other file
we also need to be able to subtract
matrices so it'll be very similar to
adding so just copy all of that paste it
down here subtract 2 matrices subtract
almost identical except that we just
need to change this plus to a minus so
it'll be M 0 data minus M 1 data so the
order is important here let's test that
right so instead of adding m0 and m1 how
about we subtract okay so 2 minus 0 is 2
4 minus 2 is 2 1 minus 1 is 0 3 minus
minus 3 is 6 minus 1 minus 1 is 0 and 0
my 0 0 good it looks like it's working
just make sure the arrow checking is
working ok so m2 minus m1 should not
work here we go error matrices are of
different dimensions great we also need
to be able to multiply two matrices
together so in a similar way that we've
subtracted them let's set up and
multiply two matrices multiply two
matrices multiply
if you know anything about matrices this
is not the dot product so it's making no
not the dot product that's a separate
thing we'll need to do that too but it's
a different operation
it's just multiplying each cell by each
cell so all we have to do is change that
- there - a times head back and test it
so matrix multiply mole multiply em to
any one shouldn't work let's just make
sure yeah it doesn't work and m0 and m1
should work good 2 times 0 0 4 times 2
is 8 1 times 1 is 1 3 times minus 3 is
minus 9 minus 1 times minus 1 is 1 0
times 0 is 0
looking good next let's calculate the
dot product let's create a function to
calculate the dot product of two
matrices so dot product of two matrices
so static dot m0 and m1 now for two
matrices to be dot compatible as such
the first ones columns must be the same
as the second ones rows for example a 4
by 2 matrix and a 2 by 4 matrix there
dot compatible the inside numbers are
the same so for example 3 by 2 and 2 by
1 they're compatible so let's test for
that if M 0 dot Cowles
doesn't equal m1 dot rows then we have
to throw an error here so throw oops
throw new error and the error message
can be just B matrices not dot dot
compatible
okey-dokey
now the size of the resulting matrix so
let's create a new matrix here let m
equal new matrix the size of the
resulting matrix is equal to the outside
numbers for example four by two and two
by four the resulting matrix will be a 4
by 4 3 by 2 times a 2 by 1 would be a 3
by 1 so that'll be the M 0 rows and the
number of columns will be the m1 dot
Cole's right next we have to do the
similar sort of loops that we've been
doing in all of these so that so for
that I equals 0 eyes less in the M rows
I plus plus and for left J equals 0 J is
less than the M Coles J plus plus so
inside here is where we need to do our
tricky stuff basically we need to add so
we need to multiply each cell of the
first matrices row by each cell of the
second matrices column and then add up
those products I'll post a link below
how to do this by hand if you're
interested so we'll need to create a
variable called sum let's sum equal 0
and another for loop for let k equal 0 k
is less than the inner number which we
the m0 coles k plus plus and then we'll
have some plus equals so we'll
continually add this together sum plus
equals the m0 data I the ithe row and
then the case column multiplied by the M
ones a data and it will be the case row
remember the inside numbers are what's
matching them by the J's sorry the J
column
I think that's right some plus equals
that and then finally we need to set the
IJ so m dot data I J will equal the sum
okey dokey
and then finally we'll need to return
that matrix return M so let's test that
out in our other file so matrix dot dot
M 0 M 1 now M 0 is a 2 by 3 matrix M 1
to 2 by 3 as well so they're not dot
compatible let's just prove that yep
error matrices are not dot compatible so
which of these are compatible
well how about M 2 m 2 times M 1 so a 2
by 2 times a 2 by 3 is dot compatible
because you know numbers are the same
let's just update this here give that a
go right so the first row entries times
the first search times the second first
column entries so 1 times 0 is 0 plus
minus 1 times 2 is minus 2 yeah
the second one so 1 times 1 is 1 plus
minus 1 times minus 3 is positive 3 is
positive 4 in total yep looks like it's
working fairly well next function that
we'd like to do is to create some sort
of conversion function to convert a
regular array to a matrix because when
we pass in our input data from our game
into the neural network we'll probably
just pass it as a regular one
dimensional array so convert array to
one Road matrix
so static converter a we'll call it
convert from array we'll pass an array
and although those returned a new matrix
new matrix with one row the columns will
equal the array dot length and the data
will just be the array itself okay let's
try that
first of all let's create an array so
let array equal just make an array of
any length with some random numbers
inside we'll want to print that out to
the console so console.log array and
we'll also want to print out the
converted array so using table so matrix
start convert from array pass our array
and we want to see the data of that okay
we don't see the rest of this stuff so
let's just comment that out let's give
that a go
incorrect data dimensions okay
something's gone wrong here 25 in our
matrix function where are we so up the
top of here page a line number 25 okay
so we failed this data integrity check I
can see why because it's checking the
data length now the length of a single
dimensioned array is the total length so
it would be 4 in our case but we don't
want that we want that to equal the rows
which is 1 so to get around that all we
have to do is created us two dimensional
array in our convert array so convert
from array here we just need to put
square brackets around that so
essentially we're putting an array
inside of an array a 2d array ok let's
give that a go
that's better
so our regular array 4 5 6 7 and our
converted array to a matrix 4 5 6 7 so
it's a 4
columned single row array great next
we'll need to create a function that can
apply a function to each cell of the
given matrix so we'll call that map so
just down here apply function to each
cell of the given matrix the reason we
need to do that I do this is because in
neural networks we'll be using a
function called the sigmoid function and
we'll need to apply it to every cell so
let's create a static method static map
which takes m0 a matrix and a function
let's call that M function and we'll
need to create a new matrix so let m
equal new matrix you'll be of the same
size as the past 2m 0 rows M 0 Cole's
will have to loop over in similar
fashion to what we've done up here so
let I equals 0 is less than M 0 dot M
rows is OK to M rows I plus plus J yep
and inside here all we need to do is get
M data I J M data I J will equal the
function of that data so the function
effect of itself effectively M data I J
and then all we have to do is return
that matrix hang on we don't want to
assign the m data because that's empty
we want to assign the m 0 data so the
one that's been passed so that data we
want to apply the function to and then
we'll assign that result to our empty
array sorry our empty matrix let's give
that a go
we don't want to see that array anymore
so console table mate
fix dot map we want to map let's just
choose one of these arrays so we'll
choose m2 and let's apply a function we
can use what they call an arrow function
so that's just x equals greater then it
looks like an arrow pointing right words
and then we can just what do we want to
do the X so x times 2 so then that means
of all times
every cell by 2 and also let's copy this
just above let's show the original table
okay let's give that a go
so the original table 1 minus 1 3 0 1
times 2 is 2 3 times 2 is 6 and so on
that's working well and one more
function so X divided by 2 say so 0.5 3
divided by 2 is 1 point 5 0 2 by yet
minus 1 divided by 2 is minus 0.5 great
that's our map function handled and the
last function for today is to find the
transpose of a matrix now the transpose
of a matrix is simply when we switch the
columns with the rows and vice versa so
find the transpose of the given matrix
so a 4 1 matrix will become a 1 4 matrix
so static trends
beause it'll just take a single matrix
as its parameter and basically we'll be
doing something very similar to this
just need to modify a few things so let
m equal new matrix we need to switch the
columns for the rows and we need to make
sure that we loop over the the original
the passed matrix so M 0 rows M 0
columns now m Delta IJ we want m data J
I M data J I will equal M 0 data IJ
let's test that out
ok so matrix start transpose
let's transpose say matrix 1 so M 1 and
we'll just put the M 1 dotted before it
ok so the original the original matrix
is 0 1 minus 1 and in the column down
here is 0 1 minus 1 2 minus 3 0 2 minus
3 0 so a 2 3 matrix has become a 3 2
matrix excellent
last time we created these matrix
functions that like for example to add
matrices and multiply them and so on
so today we're focusing entirely on
creating the neural network so first of
all let's create the class neural
network so class neural network create
the constructor
now the constructor needs to take the
number of inputs the number of hidden
and the number of outputs so num inputs
num hidden and num outputs let's set the
private variables the properties are
such so what is called given the same
name just prefix it with an underscore
num inputs equals num inputs num hidden
num hidden equals num hidden and num
outputs equals num outputs now going
back to our diagram remember we have all
these weights that are in between the
input and the hidden layer let's call
that weights 0 and recall these weights
here between the hidden and the output
weights 1 so this underscore weights 0
will equal a new matrix the number of
rows will be the number of inputs so
this is the number this num inputs and
number of columns will be the number of
hidden so this num hidden similarly
weights 1 will equal a new matrix except
that it's number of rows will be the
number of hidden and the number of
columns will be the number of outputs ok
for the weights is your own weights one
will need to set that will need to
update them during our training process
so let's create getters and setters for
them so get weights 0
that's simply return this underscore
weights zero and we'll also want to set
that so set weights zero wait wait set
weight 0 weights so we can just go this
underscore weights 0 equals weights
right and we'll do a similar thing for
weights 1 weights 1 this weights 1
weight set weights 1 this weights 1
equals weights great so we've done this
one here next we need to randomize the
initial weights so let's just use that
as our next comment
so randomize the initial weights we've
already created a function in our matrix
functions actually where we can call
randomized weights on any on any matrix
so weight 0 dot rendom weights and do a
similar thing for weights one good
that's that step done we should probably
test this so go to our other file that
HTML file and let's go down to where we
set up here we go to do neural network
so we'll have to create a variable here
the variable and n we'll call it and
here we can go NN equals new neural
network now we need to pass the number
of inputs hidden and outputs here I
think we should set them as constants so
AB where we're setting our constants
let's create a section called neural
network parameters Const
num of inputs entire show how many
inputs we'll need but let's just say 2
to begin with Const nom hidden
again there's lots of theory behind what
number this should be the higher usually
means the more complicated processing it
can do so let's just start with five we
can always adjust it later
and Const num outputs now this one I am
confident about we just want one boolean
flag zero turn left one turn right
so one output so head back down to where
we're setting up our neural network put
in these as they're the arguments and
nominee inputs num hidden and num
outputs so we don't need these matrices
anymore sick we can get rid of them to
test that our neural networks
constructor is working all right
how about we output the weights so n in
weights 0 dot data and we'll do a
similar thing hmm for weights 1 we don't
need this transpose anymore so open that
up in our web browser okay so we have
one for the first matrices of weights is
2 by 3 4 yep 2 by 5 that's right and our
output 1 our weights 1 is of 5 by 1 with
random weights inside awesome to head
over to our neural network class let's
go down and see what we need to do next
feed-forward now all that means is that
we're going to input some information
into our network it's going to feed
through it and some output is going to
be created so let's create a new method
called feed-forward
in our class it will take an input array
as an input there's a parameter let's
place these comments in here so the
first step is to convert input array to
a matrix that's easy enough so let's
declare a new array let inputs equal
matrix dot convert convert from array we
made this earlier so we can just put
the input array in there and that will
convert it to a single rode matrix
that's fine
next one find their hidden values and
apply the activation function okay to
find the hidden values we can look at
this diagram here you can see that each
hidden neuron is made up of these
weights one coming from each of the
previous inputs so to calculate that
it's just the first input multiplied by
the first weight plus the second input
times the second weight times the third
input so plus the third input times the
third way and that can be handled using
a matrix dot product we have a function
for that as well so let's hidden equal
matrix dot dot which takes two matrices
the first one being the inputs and the
second one will be the weights which we
all have already determined it's been
randomly determined so weights zero okay
now the activation function is simply
well with lots of neural networks the
activation function is something called
a sigmoid function let's take a look at
that now a sigmoid function is simply
this 1 divided by 1 plus e to the minus
T now what that does we can input any
value into this system and it will
return a value between 0 and 1 no matter
how big that value is so if we put 1
trillion into this we'll get a it'll
output a value close to 1 ok which suits
our needs very well so let's go ahead
and create a function down here just
outside our class function we'll just
call it sigmoid sigmoid it'll take some
value we'll call that X and it will
return 1 divided by 1 plus the exponent
so that's e a numeric expression
representing the power of E yep so math
dot exp to the minus X that's right now
in order to apply that function to each
of the cells of the matrix we made a
function for that too so in this K
hidden will
we'll matrix dot map okay so it takes
the the matrix so which is hidden and
the function to apply to it well we can
use an arrow function here so x equals
greater than x our sigmoid X so sigmoid
X so that should apply the sigmoid
function to each of the values within
our matrix good similarly so for the
second part find the output values and
apply the activation function it's the
same sort of thing so we can disco let
outputs equal matrix dot hidden will be
the inputs so this will be from here
from the hidden layer to the output
layer so hidden will be the inputs and
output will be the outputs so matrix dot
hidden this stop sorry hmm this dot
weights one that's the second set of
weights the outputs matrix map so itself
outputs and apply the sigmoid function
to each value and finally we want to
return return those outputs to the
sender the next step apply bias I don't
want to do that right now and the reason
is because not applying bias can cause
issues and I'd like to see what those
issues are so this first test this
feed-forward function so let's do some
console output console.log inputs and
we'll the set up with the the data in
the array so we can use table for that
console the table inputs dot data and
we'll do something similar each step of
the way here so when we work out our
hidden neurons we can just do that and
we'll also want to see what happens
after we apply the sigmoid function
similarly for our outputs
and after the outputs have had the
sigmoid function applied to them so I'll
just call that output sig that will be
hidden sig okay head over to our other
file let's call that function so all we
have to do is go n n dot feed forward it
requires an input array so something
like 0 comma 1 now remembering that the
number of inputs that we declared for
our neural network is 2 so we need to
pass to Al an array of length 2 here now
if we didn't let's just try that if we
didn't it should break there's at the
open our file open up the console yeah
so input Scott through a single length
array but there's an error matrices are
not dot compatible so to fix that all we
have to do is put the second element put
the second input in there let's give
that a go
yep that works fine so we've got two
inputs 0 and 1 the hidden values are
calculated I'll just believe that the
sigmoid is applied the output and the
sigmoid is applied let's just keep
resetting that until we get an output
that is negative here we go so here's a
negative output can you see that the
sigmoid function has made that positive
so that seems to be working ok so head
over to our other file we can probably
get rid of some of these console logs so
let's just delete a few of them we'll
keep one set we'll probably need it for
our next function and that is trained
trained using input and target arrays
right so currently our system doesn't do
very much we give it some inputs and it
outputs some randomly generated outputs
not very useful so in order to make it
do something how about we create a
function that allows us to put in some
training data so we'll call that train
so up inside our class train it will
take in
put array and the target array so for
example if we had the inputs zero and
one and we expect one to be the answer
then that's what we would put in here
let's paste those comments in there
so the first step feed the input data
through the network well we already have
a function for that called feed-forward
so let's say let outputs equal
feed-forward this dot feed-forward the
input array okay that's that done next
calculate the output errors target minus
output okay in order to subtract
matrices we'll have to convert the
target array first so that lets targets
equal matrix convert convert from our
from our a target array okay good
and let's output errors so we're
calculating the output errors here that
output errors equal matrix dot subtract
and we'll subtract the first which is
the target so that targets minus the
second which is the outputs the outputs
let's test that so I'll grab this
console data that we kept up here output
targets and output errors so outputs
that'll be fine
targets targets and output errors output
errors let's print out every step okay
head back over to our other file and
then dot train
we need an input array 0 1 and an output
array remembering it has to match the
number of outputs if it doesn't we're
going to get an error we'll just give
that a go we'll put a 2 column 1 there
I guess an error matrices are of
different dimensions so when it tries to
subtract them it failed so let's put
that to a single one right so we have
our outputs which is point six three
nine the expected the target is one so
the difference is 0.36 that sounds
correct so on to our next step calculate
the deltas which are equal to the errors
times the derivative of the output so
the derivative of the output is actually
the derivative of the sigmoid function
so let's update our sigmoid function to
handle derivatives how about we just
pass a flag the Riv equals false we'll
sit we'll give it a default values that
you don't have to provide it and if you
don't it'll just return what we always
have if de rêve then we'll return the
derivative now the derivative of this is
x times 1 minus x that's not the true
derivative of the sigmoid function but
we've already applied the sigmoid
function so we don't want to return the
truth so I'll put a note here where x
equals sigmoid X right so the true
derivative is the sigmoid x times 1
minus the sigmoid X but we've already
applied it so this will be a good
representation x times 1 minus X so
let's create a variable let now put the
R is equal we can use our map function
to apply this matrix top map the outputs
and the function will be we can use an
arrow function again will be the sigmoid
X but this time we'll set the derivative
to it'll apply the derivative to each of
these outputs and assign it to that and
finally output errors know Kappa the
delsar output deltas is what we're
trying to find here output deltas will
equal matrix dot so arrows times
derivative so multiply
we can use our multiply function the
first one is the errors output errors
and the second one will be the output
derivatives output derivatives and what
does copy this console.log here so we
can test this output just the deltas
will do output deltas let's test that I
was running again so we have output
targets output errors and output deltas
Who am I to refute that it looks ok ok
on to the next step calculate hidden
layer errors so it's the deltas dot the
transpose of weights one right so let's
calculate the transpose first so we'll
call it weights 1 capital T for
transpose will equal we have a function
for this matrix transpose it just takes
a single matrix so that'll be the this
dot weights one okay and then we'll need
to calculate the hidden layer errors
will collect the hidden there is hidden
errors will equal Delta dot so matrix
dot what was the first one the deltas
dot the transpose
okay so that'll be the output deltas
output deltas dot what we just worked
out the transpose their weights 1t again
let's output some just to make sure it's
not throwing error basically we don't
really know exactly what we're after
here the hidden errors is what we'll
want an output here hidden errors let's
give it a go
right so we get some output deltas and
then we get the hidden errors across
ways that looks to be okay so the next
step
calculate the hidden deltas errors times
derivative of hidden sounds very similar
to what we've done up here so let's just
copy and paste that let hidden derives
equal matrix map hidden I just had a
thought
we don't have actually have visibility
to hidden here hidden because hidden
wasn't was used within this feed-forward
function here we go let hidden equals
that so how about instead of creating a
local variable here we use a property on
our neural network we'll say this dot
hidden this dot hidden so anywhere we
use hidden inside here we'll go this
hidden this stuff hidden this hidden and
we'll have to go create a property on
the neural network so we can do that
easily enough to say the top of it this
start underscore hidden well does equal
an empty array and we'll have to set up
some getters and setters for it so that
we can access it get hidden we'll just
return this underscore hidden and set
hidden just pass her variable called
hidden this hidden will equal hidden
that should access yep that's the same
as that right so that should all work in
our feed forward now and back down where
we have back in the trained function
where we have hidden here so hinder if
she will the matrix map this start
hidden so we're accessing the actual
hidden values at this state at this
point in time X sigmoid X is true yet
we're applying the derivative of it cap
at the hidden Delta so the hidden deltas
matrix-multiply the hidden errors times
the hidden dreams right so let's output
those hidden deltas let's give it a go
so we have some hidden errors with some
hidden deltas good now for the final
step in our little neural network update
the weights we have to add the transpose
of layers deltas 3 add that to the
weights
ok so let's first calculate the
transpose so let hidden transpose equal
matrix dot transpose this dot hidden
sorry next we have to add the transpose
to the weight so this weights the
Associated weights is 1 it's the second
set of weights equal matrix add add
itself we have to add to itself so this
weights 1 the layers the transversus
layers deltas so matrix dot the
transpose hidden T hidden T and the
deltas which will be the output deltas
of the associate are associated with the
hidden layer to output deltas now we
have to do a similar thing for the first
weight so weights 0 so we need to
calculate the transpose of the inputs so
inputs t what matrix transpose in do we
have inputs do we have visibility on
inputs no we don't because again within
the feed-forward we're converting it
there and keeping it as a local variable
so there's a couple things we could do
we could just convert it again within
our training array
but we have to remember that this train
functional probably called like
thousands of times if not hundreds of
thousands of times so it's probably
better just to assign it to what how
we're doing with the hidden here so
let's do that this start inputs this
inputs and wants to go up and create a
property same as what we've done for
hidden so this inputs will just equal an
empty array and we have to create a
couple of with Korea together and a
setter get inputs this return this
inputs set inputs inputs Siebels inputs
this inputs will equal inputs that's
looking good so our feed-forward
function should work now we're just a
sign instead of creating a local
variable we're just assigning as a
property now down in our train function
this inputs should work now that's fine
and we're updating weights zero at this
point
weight zero weight zero dot the inputs
teeth inputs t and the deltas that are
associated without other hidden Delta's
the next layer deltas let's run that
make sure that's not broken
okay it's not breaking so that's good
enough test for me I think we should
actually try this training and see if it
actually works or not how about we get
rid of all these comments first because
they're just not we don't want them
printing out every iteration when we've
got like a thousand or ten thousand
iterations remove all then remove all
them this weights updating great go back
to our other file right so we'll be
calling train but we want to loop over
the number of training samples that we
have so in go for I'll title this train
the network
for let I equals 0 I is less than say
let's set up her flag for this enum
samples I plus plus in there we'll do
our training for something a number of
samples let's go up and create that now
num samples not exactly sure how many
we'll need but let's start at say 1000 I
know in other examples there's 10,000
and a hundred thousand and so on we'll
just we'll start with 1000 number
samples is 1000 and how about we use the
classic example to test neural networks
is the ZOA
so the xor gate the exclusive or gate so
X well call this a test test X or gate
logic let's take a look at that XOR gate
here it is just this table down here so
when you have two inputs 0 0 output 0 0
1 or 1 0 output 1 and 1 1 outputs 0 so 0
0 0 ok let's write that in here I think
0 0 equals 0 0 1 equals 1 1 0 equals 1
and 1 1 equals 0 so only when there's
one of them flagged will it be 1
otherwise when they're both the same
it'll be 0 so let's create some random
input will create 1 0 1 there and 1 0 1
there so we'll input 1 input 2 or input
0 and input 1 input 0 will equal well
it'll be a random number and we want to
round it so math round just rounds to
the nearest integer and we want around a
random number math.random which is a
number between 0 and 1 so that should
produce a 0 or 1 similarly for input
one so we can pass them into our
training array here so input is your own
input one and we also need an output so
let output that output equal what's the
logic behind it if input 1 input 0 and
input 1 are the same
then the output is 0 right otherwise the
output is 1 so we just do a conditional
here input 0 equals input 1 if that's
true the output is 0 else the output is
1
that's the zuhr gate logic and put our
output into this array here out put but
basically we've created a whole bunch of
random training data with the correct
outputs fed it into our system in the
hope that it's going to create an
accurate prediction so let's test it
test output we can just use the console
for this I think console.log will put in
each of the combinations of inputs so 0
0 will equal let's feed it into our
system together to get a prediction feed
forward we need the array 0 comma the
input array 0 0 and we want to output to
the screen the data of that so do that
for each of the possible input
combinations so 0 1 1 0 and 1 1 0 0 0 1
1 0 & 1 1 let's give that a go
hey K 0 zeroes we're expecting a 0 here
and a 0 here and a 1 here and a 1 here
it could be that we haven't got enough
samples so let's try it by bumping up
the number of samples to say 10,000
now that's looking pretty good that's
close to zero that's close to one that's
close to one that's close to zero let's
just keep trying make sure there's no
discrepancies here now I have read that
not having bias can cause an issue in
these situations so let's see if it
comes up with a strange reading on
occasion so here for example the
prediction for one one is 0.5 so that
could be because of the bias not being
there so I think for safety we should
put the bias in so first of all what is
bias well here's a diagram basically we
have our input neurons we just add an
extra neuron for bias it always takes a
value of positive 1 and we add it and
all it does is output its own weights in
effect it doesn't take an input of any
kind it just outputs its own weight
we'll have one bias node on the input
layer and one bias node on the hidden
layer the reason we do this is because
the input neurons could take all zeros
for example in ours or gate logic if we
have zero zero as our inputs can you see
that that could skew the results because
zero times any of these weights will be
zero so it's not going to behave
correctly so that's why we add this bias
node I head into our other file go right
at the top in the same way that we've
created weights here let's create a bias
zero and the bias for one so bias zero
will equal a new matrix of just a single
row so one row the number of columns
will be the number of hidden and bias
one same sort of thing one row but the
number of columns will be the number of
outputs okay and we'll have to randomize
in the same way that we've randomized
the other weights will randomize the
bias so bias zero
Riaan
weights do that for bias one as well
okay that looks good head down to our
feed-forward function we've left a note
here apply bias to apply the bias all we
have to do is before we apply the
sigmoid function to the hidden layer we
can just apply we can add the bias so
this hidden will equal matrix add this
hidden to adding to itself this bias 0
so that is applying the bias apply bias
and in the same way we'll do that with
the output so before we apply the
sigmoid function instead we'll be doing
it to the output so outputs will equal
matrix add outputs this bias one now
down in our train function we've left a
note update biases now to do all we have
to do there is go in the same way that
we've updated our weights here we'll do
the same thing this the bias 1 will
equal matrix add this bias 1 and we're
adding the deltas the output deltas for
this one same sort of thing for the bias
0 except that we'll be adding the hidden
deltas so this bias zero hidden Delta's
so let's test that oh we have an error
m1 is undefined okay
M bias maybe no I didn't create the
getters and setters for these private so
let's do that now that was a bit silly
so we're just as we do just as we get
and set the weights let's get and set
the bias so bias 0 this bias the
set bias zero and this bias zero just
passed the bias oops
bias bias okay so but get by so you
return this bio set by zero bias this by
severe equals bias do that for bias one
as well just update that one one one and
one okay that should be okay now let's
give that a go
great so if we run that a few times my
hunch is that it will be fine we'll get
a value close to zero a value close to
one and finally a value close to zero
it will actually be feeding in-game data
into our neural network so that we can
rotate this ship I'm doing this manually
of course so we can rotate the ship and
shoot at the closest asteroid ok so into
our code I'll just turn automation back
on ok and head to our neural network
file but the first thing I'd like to do
today is to set up some error logging in
our neural network class the reason for
this is that I'd like to be able to keep
track of how well our training function
is doing as we're training it so let's
set up a flag up here just a constant
let's call it log on set it to true and
that's just whether or not to show error
logging and we'll need to keep track of
how often we show this message like show
a message we don't to show it every
iteration because we could in theory
you'd be calling this train function
like thousands of hundreds of thousands
of times if not millions of times so
let's set a log frequency initially
we'll set it to a thousand say and
that's just how often to show error
logging error logs and that's in
iterations in iterations ok we'll have
to set up a private member variable here
just down here so error logging this
underscore will keep track of how many
calls we've had or how many iterations
we'll call it log count and it'll start
the day at log frequency and we'll also
because it's private we'll want to set
up some getters and setters it's not
technically private I'm kind of making
it private I should say so get log count
get logged count returned this log count
set log count count this log count
equals count head down to our train
function now what's the most appropriate
thing to output here I'm thinking the
output errors because the output errors
are simply the target - the output so if
the targets 1 and the outputs point 7
then the error is 0.7 it's easy to
understand so let's do our error logging
here error logging if log on and if the
this dot log count yep if this lot log
count equals the log frequency well
let's do a console output so console log
output errors output errors now it's a
matrix so we'll need to grab its data
array and we there's only going to be
one error because we've only got one
piece of output so we'll just do the
first column sorry the first row first
cell okay probably prefix out with
something so we know that what we're
outputting error equals that then we'll
have to decrement the log count so this
start log count - - because we don't
want it occurring every iteration and
when that reaches zero if this log count
equals zero what will we do well we'll
just reset it this log count equals log
frequency
let's test that out so currently we all
just need to turn our console on reset
it okay here we go so we got errors of
point three two point two nine point
zero eight that's going down slowly
isn't it how about so this is ours or
gate logic that we used last time how
about we increase the number of samples
so go back to our other file our HTML
file we'll increase the number of
samples to say 100,000 and we'll
increase the number of hidden nodes to
ten but because we're doing a hundred
thousand samples now how about we change
our log frequency to say ten thousand we
don't want it showing so often let's
give that a go Oh point seven four point
zero one as you can see very quickly the
error is reduced with the zahl gate
logic so that's good our logging is
working great that's all we really need
to do for our neural network file so
let's head over to our other file now we
have to think about how many inputs are
there going to be in our system I've
always said that the goal was to turn
our ship towards the closest asteroid
and shoot it so knowing that we need to
know the asteroids position don't we so
there's going to be it an x position and
the Y position so that's two inputs and
we also need to know the ship's angle
because if we're facing this way we need
to know that we'll have to turn left to
get to the asteroid or turn right or
whatever so that's the asteroid X Y
asteroid Y and the ships angle so
that'll be a minimum of three inputs how
about just for testing purposes we'll
just turn the riod number down to one
there'll be a single asteroid right head
down to where we set up our neural
network where we train the network we
don't need to do any of this or gate
logic anymore that was just for testing
our system and we don't need this test
output anymore
so let's create some variables well
honey the asteroids exposition asteroids
y-position the ship's our angle and just
for completeness let's include the
ship's position as well so ship X and
ship Y so the first thing we'd like to
do the first thing that we'd like to
include in our training data is a random
asteroid location random asteroid
location but we have to remember that
asteroids can float off the left and
right of screen as well as top and
bottom up to their radius so we'll have
to include off screen data here as well
so a X will equal a random point random
times by the width of the screen so
canvas top width but because it can go
up to its radius off the left and it's
radius off the right well that will mean
we'll have to add the total width the
size of the right here royde size which
is the diameter in effect bracket that
and then flight so that'll generate a
number a number between 0 and say the
width is 500 so 500 plus 100 is 600 so 0
and 600 but we want it to be able to be
negative so we'll have to subtract the
radius so it'll be the Royd size - the
Royd size divided by 2 which is the
radius do a similar thing for a Y except
that it will be the height good and now
the ship's angle and position now the
ships angle it must be random
we'll just randomly generate an angle
anywhere between 0 and 360 degrees so in
radians just do a math.random first
math.random times 360 degrees in in
radians which is just pi times 2 good
now the X location and the wire location
I'm not planning to move the ship at all
that'll be far too complicated and I
think it's a pretty good strategy just
to sit in the middle turn to the nearest
asteroid and shoot so we'll keep it
fixed
SX will just equal the ships starting
sorry this chips starting X and sy will
just equal the ships starting Y next
we'll need to work out which direction
to turn based on the angle of our ship
and the angle of the asteroid so
calculate the angle to the asteroid how
about where you write a function for
this because it's possible that we'll
use it again just down here function
will give it a generic name such as
angle to point angle to point we'll have
to use some trigonometry here so we need
to know our current position so x and y
will need to know our facing or bearing
will call that bearing we'll need to
know that's Hargett s-- X&Y location
target X and target Y and I think that's
what we need to know so let's angle to
target so let anger to target equal well
it'll have to be the inverse tan because
we have x and y coordinates so tan is
opposite over adjacent so a 10 there's
two types of a tans here there's a tan
which is our regular mathematics tangent
but that doesn't take into consideration
coordinate space you know we have four
quadrants in coordinate space but a 10-2
does taking the consideration that so
we'll use that now it requires a Y and
an X so we'll have to find the
differences between our target and our
self so we'll put so this would be the Y
differences so it'll be target why - why
right and the exes will be the similar a
similar thing targets X minus X however
because Y's on screen like pixel lies
are in the opposite direction so as we
go up the screen we're actually going in
a negative y-direction so I'll have to
apply a negative to that and a negative
to that so it'll be minus target y plus
y target X minus X Y X yep that's good
we'll have to find the differences
between our angle to the target and our
bearing so we can just go let say diff
equal our bearing minus the angle to
target angle to target now that could
result in a whole range of numbers
because this a 10-2 function it returns
a number between effectively 180 degrees
and minus 180 degrees so it could be
negative our bearing could be anywhere
between 0 and 360 so just say it was 0
and we had 180 here we'll get a negative
number won't we if the bearing is say
360 and our angle is minus we'll get a
number over 360 so we'll need to do some
normalizing as such here so how about we
have or we can just return this I think
return the diff remembering we can add
360 degrees to any angle and it's still
the same effective angle if I'm facing
40 degrees and I add 360 degrees so 400
degrees I'm still facing at the same
angle anti so we will add the we'll add
360 degrees math pi times 2 but that
could get us above 360 couldn't it it'll
get us above 0 which is what we want but
it could also get us way above 360 so
we'll find the modulus of that the
remainder so modulus
math.pi times 2 so that will guarantee
us a result
between 0 and 360 degrees in effect in
radians right so back up here we can
just
let angle say angle equal call that
function angle angle to point we have to
pass the correct parameters so the X is
our ship location ship X ship Y the
bearing is the ship's angle the target X
is the asteroid X and the target why is
asteroid Y so that'll give us our
absolute angle as such and then we need
to determine the direction to turn
alright so that's probably let's say let
Direction equal well if that angle is
greater than 180 degrees so angle is
greater than math.pi that's 180 degrees
then we'd like to turn left so remember
with the UM put in 0 1 here how about we
set these as constants I think that
would be the best move so back up here
in our neural network parameters let's
have constants out put left will equal 0
so that will be the expected output
expected neural output for turning left
similarly we'll have the output right
which will equal 1 and that'll be the
expected neural output for turning right
ok so back down here if the angles
greater than 180 math.pi will output
left else will output right so finally
we just need to train the network so we
can call a neural network trained to do
that it takes an input array so the
input array is just our position of our
asteroid ax and a Y and the angle of the
ship and the output array the expected
array is just an array with direction in
it it's just a single length sorry a 1
length
right that's our training so we'll be
training that every iteration now I
foresee one problem where this a X a Y
and si they take on strange values
though a X could be a number like 600 a
Y could be minus 23 si could be 3.8 or
whatever have they're not normalized are
they but let's see what they do it might
not be an issue okay you can see that
these errors don't seem to be getting
any better
let's pump up the number of pump up the
number of samples just while we're here
we'll that's the number of training
samples so we'll pump that up to 1
million let's see what that does to me
that looks like it's not getting
anywhere because these errors are still
incredibly large they're not getting any
closer to 0 so I don't like that so I
think we'll need to normalize our data
and put that back - we'll put that back
to 100,000 I don't think we need a
million samples but 100,000 should do us
head back down to our training here
we'll need to normalize this starter
here before we input it into the
training array so how about we create
method a new function called say
normalized input or similar so just
before shoot laser function normalize
input will need to pass the roids X
location the roids Y location and our
ships angle there are three neural
inputs now all we mean by normalizes
normalize the values to between 0 and 1
so we'll divide them by something in
order to get them to be between 0 and 1
so let's create a new array an empty
array
called input let input equal empty array
and input 0 that will be our roid
x-value we'll need to know normally you
can just go roid X divided by the canvas
width that would give give us our screen
position our relative screen position
but because we've allowed it to be
off-screen up to its radius then we'll
need to modify this so roid X so that
could be negative 50 it could be
negative it could be the negative radius
it could be negative 50 so whether add
the radius back to that to get it back
to zero so roid size divided by two and
we'll have to divide all of that by the
new canvas width including the radius on
the left and right so that'll be canvas
width plus the diameter which is just
the roid size let's just work through
that logically so royde X could be minus
50 so minus 50 plus 50 equals zero zero
divided by anything is going to be zero
that's fine now the maximum value this
could take would be to say we'll choose
an arbitrary width of 500 so 500 plus 50
is 550 plus 50 is 600 600 divided by 500
plus 100 is 600 so that'll be one that's
good and halfway between say 250 250
plus the radius of 50 is 300 300 divided
by 500 plus 100 six hundred three
hundred divided by six hundred equals
0.5 that sounds good we'll do the
similar sort of thing for the X sorry
for the Y position except that we use
the height instead
now the next one ships angle that this
is a bit of an easier exercise all we
have to do is divide the past angle so
that'll be a number between 0 and 360 in
effect in radians we have to divide that
by 360 so math
hi times two so an angle of zero divided
by that would be zero an angle of 360
divided by that would equal one and
everything in between that's great let's
return that input array so let's go up
and implement that in our training
section train the network so all we have
to do is normalize this start of
beforehand normalize input before we put
it through our chain function let's give
that a go it's looking better at least
it's getting closer to zero there's some
discrepancies here maybe we just need to
modify some of the parameters here so
how about we bump up a number of hidden
to say 20 and we'll set our number of
samples to say 500,000 just while we're
here we may as well change the number of
the amount of logging but step change
that to say every 20,000 instead okay
let's give that a go so it's a bit
slugged because we've got more hidden
neurons but it does look like it's
getting better the the errors aren't too
bad are they look at that one down the
bottom very close to zero so I think
we've done quite well with that if we
put that if we put the hidden nodes back
to ten
they'll speed it up a bit will that
impact the quality let's have a look
that's pretty good too actually either
way well let's leave it at 20 and
500,000 number of training examples just
while we're here I'm thinking that we'll
need an output threshold because none of
these predictions are going to be
exactly zero or exactly one are they but
they might be close so how about we
create a threshold for example 0.25 just
an arbitrary value to begin with and
this is how close the prediction must be
so how close the prediction must be to
commit to a turn so at point two five
for example if the prediction is 0.75 or
greater we would commit to a right turn
if the prediction was less than 0.25
we'd commit to a left turn however if
the prediction was say 0.5 we won't do
anything we'll just sit in the middle
well so how about we start implementing
some of this so let's go down to well
first of all let's see what happens when
we push the left and right arrow keys so
in the keydown method so when we've got
manual control this all we're doing is
setting the ship's rotation to this how
about we create a function that can
handle because when we turn right it's
the same thing except we're going the
opposite direction so let's pull those
out and create a function for that
because we'll need to call this function
what will we call it rotate ship it'll
pass a boolean will say that false
equals left-right false equals left and
here we'll rotate ship true so it'll be
right and let's what are we doing the
key up method the key up just sets the
ship's rotation to zero so that's fine
we don't need to do anything with that
so ahead let's go down make that rotate
ship just after our normalized input
function Road rotate ship it'll take a
balloon which is equal to right so we'll
be doing that now if it's right we want
to put that as negative so how about we
make a variable called say let sign
equal now if it's right if it's right
the sign will be minus one else it will
be positive run and will doesn't
multiply this by the sign that should be
okay just to make sure we haven't broken
anything how about we turn it back into
manual mode so automation on is false
and make sure that we can control this
ship yep I can turn left and right no
problem that's all good
put that back to true and now let's go
down to our update function where is
that down here to do control the ship so
we'll need to make prediction make a
prediction based on current data so
let's make some variables so we need to
know the asteroids X which will equal
roads will just use because there's only
one asteroid to begin with we'll just
use roids zero for the time being
Lloyd zero dot X similarly a why will
they call roids sorry
roids zero dot and we also need to know
the ship's angle don't we so that's just
the ship a ship dot a now to make a
prediction how we go let predict equal
we just need to run our feed-forward
function feed feed-forward it will take
the input array so input array will be
ax but we have to normalize this don't
we so hang on do the normalized first
normalize input it takes the roids X so
ax ay Y and the ships angle the lies
input remember that returns a matrix and
output matrix so we'll have to take its
data and there's only going to be one
output so it'll be the first column and
the first so the first row first column
0 0 that should be our prediction
now we need to decide which way to turn
so make turn now we're going to get a
value it's not going to be exactly zero
it's not gonna be exactly one so how
about we find the difference between it
the between the prediction and our left
and right turns so let we'll call it
Delta left or difference left what are
you gonna call it Delta left will equal
the prediction make this the absolute
value math absolute value it'll be the
prediction minus the output constant
output left right and Delta right will
equal the prediction minus the output
right so let's just try to analyze that
so the prediction just say the
prediction is 0.2 all right
so 0.2 minus output left is point two
that means there's only it's point two
units close to the left point two minus
one is point eight the absolute value
will be point eight so that's not going
to be what we want to do so we'll have
to compare it what to compare these to
our thresholds okay
so if Delta left is less than our output
threshold so if it's less than 0.25 or
whatever value we choose to set it at
then we wish to rotate left rotate ship
now left is just false okay else if
Delta right is less than the output
threshold then we will rotate the ship
right which is true now if it's neither
so for example point five point five -
yup what left is 0.5 0.5 - output right
it's not going to be less than the
threshold in either of these situations
so how about we just put an else here
saying that
stop rotating so if it's not confident
it'll stay still so ship dot rotate
equals zero so that's equivalent to us
releasing the arrow keys I think we
should just log this prediction here so
console.log predict just so we can see
if there's any problems with it
okie dokie let's try it so we're just
training it to begin with with 500,000
samples the errors look pretty good that
one wasn't very good okie dokie what's
it doing it seems to be stuck
I know how it is turning it's kind of
slowly turning towards the asteroid will
it turn when it goes past it yes it's
okay it's maybe not the best now I
wonder why we'll just watch it a bit
longer it's kind of getting confused a
bit isn't it okay I've been watching
this for a while now it looks like
something's going wrong because it
eventually the ship no matter how many
times you run it the ship eventually
starts spinning around in its inner
circle without and it's got these really
very confident predictions so see this
prediction here it's very real as close
to zero so i guessing something's going
wrong with our angle so let's go into
our code maybe we should log the angle
here ship dot angle let's see what that
does
okay sliding the training data again
okay so the angle remember it'll be a
number between 0 and 2pi which is about
6 or so now that's not good see the
angles going negative there we want the
angle to be 0 between 0 and 2pi so
there's something I think I might know
what's wrong if we head down to where we
rotate our ship in the update function
I suspect that we're just letting it add
on endlessly we are so for example the
ship out the ship angle can just keep
going up and up and up and up so it'll
go beyond 720 and so on it could go
below 0 no problems which is fine it was
working fine in the game but for our
prediction we want it to be between 0
and 360 so we want to keep the angle
between 0 and 360 which is 2 pi remember
2 pi so if the ship's angle is less than
0 we'll need to add 360 to it
remembering if we add 360 it'll still be
the same angle so plus equals math.pi we
need to bracket this I'm not sure I'm
not sure what the order of operations
are for these e
yeah these assignment operators what
does bracket it won't hurt math times 2
so we'll add 360 to it else if ships
angle is greater than or equal to 360
360 math times a bracket this one as
well math dot pi times 2 if it's greater
than that then we'll want to subtract
we'll want to do the same thing except
that we'll subtract 360
we don't want exactly 360 because our
randomly generated position will never
be 360 I don't think minus equals that
and that should do it let's give that a
go
let's load it up loading the training
data
so the training data looks pretty good
it should be working quite well okay I
think that's acting a lot better where's
the asteroid there's yes Troy yeah I
think it's tracking it quite well I
think that was our problem yep so it's
choosing the first asteroid which is
whatever's in the in the array first in
the array and following it good okay how
about we add some shooting to this
little ship so let's head back all the
way up to the top to set some parameters
so we'll probably need to give the ship
a rate of fire
so just in under our neural network
parameters here let's create one called
rate of fire and we'll set that to say
five shots per second so it shots per
second we'll also need to keep track of
how many frames we count down to the
next shot so where we set up our neural
network here let's just put in a new
something called say a I shoot time and
we'll set that to zero to begin with
where will we update that where we'll
update that in now or to where we do our
prediction so just after we make a turn
now what's the strategy for firing when
when when will we shoot well we could
shoot just when it's not rotating but
that's not really what I do I keep
turning into shooting all the time
because eventually going to get lucky -
so how about we just shoot all the time
it'll shoot as often as it can so shoot
the laser if AI shoot time equals zero
which will it'll start at zero then we
want to reset that AI shoot time not
this AI shoot time will equal the frame
rate divided by the rate of fire I think
we should find the ceiling of that math
dot seal so if we had a frame rate of 30
divided by the rate of fire of 5 that
will every sixth frame
we'll shoot if it was ten so 30/10 would
have would be shooting every third frame
so quite quickly we'll need to shoot the
laser shoot laser just checking that
function because part of that condition
is that the ship can shoot and when we
shoot a laser the ship can't shoot
that's because the player must push the
space key then release it so we'll have
to set that up to be able to handle that
well we can we can just do it here ship
that can shoot equals true so whenever
it can fire we'll let it fire else so if
the AI ship time doesn't equal zero
we'll want to countdown our shoot time -
- so this is just counting down the
frames left so let's give this a go so
loading in our training data so
hopefully this little ship will follow
the first asteroid and just keep
shooting at it until it's destroyed and
then it'll follow the next asteroid yeah
that's what it's doing bang boom boom
bang yeah just keep shooting it's pretty
effective actually even when we're not
targeting the closest asteroid so how
about we program it to target the
closest one so head back into our update
function so compute the closest asteroid
we'll need to keep track of the index so
how about we just make a variable called
say let's see equal zero so this will be
the closest index in the array we'll
need to calculate the distance wanted to
keep track of the closest distance so
we'll call that say distance zero will
equal we have our method for calculating
distance distance between points the x1
y1 so the ship
X the ship y
the X 2 will be the asteroids 0 dot X
roids 0 dot lie and then we'll have to
loop through each of the asteroids so
for let I equal 0 actually let it equal
1 because we've already calculated the
first one distance 0 then so that I call
1 I is less than the asteroids length
roids dot length I plus plus and then we
need to get the distance of the current
asteroids or Colette distance one
distance 1 will equal distance it's
going to be the same thing really
basically except that we'll be using I
instead of 0 here and then all we have
to do is do a check to see if that one's
that distance is smaller less than the
current distance so if distance 1 is
less than distance 0 that means it's
smaller doesn't it so we'll replace
distance 0 distance 0 will equal
distance 1 and we'll want to update our
index closest index so C will equal I so
all we have to do is put that C in to
where we've got 0 down the answer a X
will equal roy's see a while-- equal
ride C dot y and let's give that a go
loading our training data again so
hopefully it'll turn towards the closest
asteroid and shoot at it there's only
one asteroid here that reminds me we
should probably up the number of
starting asteroids back to its original
so Roy number will equal 3
save that load it one more time
okay is it turning towards the closest
one certainly it's not shooting the
farthest away ones anyway so it's doing
fairly well it's not perfect I'm
thinking we could probably make this a
little bit better I think we'll do one
more one more update to our little
function here how about we pass some
more information because we're only
passing kind of the bare minimum we're
passing the asteroid location and the
ship's angle I think we can do better
than that so head back into the code get
down to where we set up our training
data what else could we pass well we are
calculating the angle to the asteroid
how about we stick that in as one of our
inputs so we'll put it in after our
asteroid position we'll have to bump up
the number of inputs to four so down
here our normalized input we'll have to
add an extra here we'll pull it roid
angle roid angle it'll be our third one
it's gonna be very similar to how we do
the ship angle we'll just put roid angle
there roid angle ship angle update its
index two three wherever we call this
what that fix it up which is just down
in our update function so we'll have to
pass an angle in there and have to
calculate that angle so what do we need
to know for that we need to know the
ship's x and y coordinates so s X will
equal ship dot X you don't really have
to do this but this is just to make it
clear ships Y ship dot Y and let angle
equal angle angle to point now what does
it take x and y which is the ship X and
the ship why it takes the bearing which
is the ship's angle the target X which
is the asteroids X and the asteroids y
and then we'll pass that in through our
feed-forward function to get a
prediction I don't think we need to log
this anymore if this is prediction now
let's take a look at that okay imported
um doing our training where are those
errors are very small so they're eetu
the -15 there's a couple of zeros in
there so they're very precise so looking
at our ships performance yeah he's doing
pretty well he should be doing very well
the only issue I can see is that see
that jitter there that's because we're
only making a prediction every frame if
we increased our frame rate we could
probably make that better and also if we
reduced our threshold to decide whether
we turn or not so let's do that now so
head up to the top will reduce our
output threshold to say point zero five
that means in order to make a right turn
we'd have to have 0.95 confidence let's
increase the rate of fire for fun to say
two 15 shots per second and we want to
increase our frame rate to say 60 let's
give that a go
way okay just loading our training data
the errors are very very good and here
he goes wow we've created a monster so
with his increased with his increased
rate of fire and the faster frame rate
he can make more accurate more subtle
turns and really pepper those asteroids
with laser fire cool so anyway that's
the end of our tutorial series so we've
gone from using a matrix maths to
creating a neural network only a fairly
simple neural network but a neural
network all the same I hope you've
learned a lot from this I certainly have
because I had to do a lot of research in
figuring all this stuff out but in the
end we managed to use our network to
control the simple game such as
asteroids and this is
result I wonder how far he could go how
far could this what level could this
ship reach well anyway I feel free to
download the code and try it out for
yourself update the parameters have a
play and learn something new until next
time talk to you then bye
[Applause]
[Applause]